[موسيقى]
كل يوم من هذه الحرب جلب الألم،
الألم الذي لا يريد أحد الوالدين أن يخففه
عن كل 15 دقيقة في غزة،
يُقتل طفل، وتقول جماعات الإغاثة إن أكثر من 1500
طفل قتلوا حتى الآن في حرب كانت
مجرد بداية لحرب قاموا بها.  لا
يختارون خيارًا يدفعون ثمنه باهظًا، أولئك
الذين يعيشون مسكونًا بما
نجوا منه، المحظوظون لا يزال
لديهم آباء يمسكون
بأيديهم عبد الرحمن البالغ من العمر 10 سنوات، لا يزال
لا يعرف أن الضربة التي
تركته مصابًا أخذته بعيدًا  أمه وأبيه
وشقيقاته الثلاث، عمته هي الوحيدة التي بقيت
لتحاول تهدئته، يستيقظ
ويبكي ويعطونه مسكنات للألم
ويعود للنوم،
تقول [موسيقى] إن العائلات هنا تقول إنهم استجابوا جميعًا
لتحذير الجيش الإسرائيلي وانتقلوا
جنوبًا  معتقدة أن الأمر سيكون آمنًا ولكن
لم تكن إصابة ميك في الوركين
والساقين، فقد فقدت والدتها وإخوتها في
غارة جوية. كان محمود البالغ من العمر 9 سنوات يلعب
عندما أصيب منزل عائلته وهو في
المستشفى برأسه وساقه.
الموسيقى]
الإصابات يقول الأطباء إن معظم المصابين في غزة
هم من الأطفال والنساء الذين
لا كهرباء ولا مياه وإمدادات طبية
تنفد، والرعاية الصحية التي يحتاجونها
على وشك
الانهيار، ونصف سكان غزة هم من
الأطفال، وأغلبهم لم يعرفوا الحياة إلا في
ظل ظروف قاسية.  الحصار والحرب الآن في
منطقة القتل هذه، لا يوجد مكان آمن من القصف الإسرائيلي
المستمر،
اليائسين للحصول على أي وعد
بالسلامة، لقد غمر الكثيرون مستشفى الشفاء، وأصبح
الطنين المستمر
للطائرات العسكرية بدون طيار في السماء جزءًا من
الوجود في
غزة، يجد البعض القليل من الهروب من هذا
الكابوس الحي  لا ينبغي لأي طفل
أن يتحمل لين وتقول جوليا إن
حيهم قد سوّي بالأرض بسبب الهواء
[موسيقى]
يضرب جوليا البالغة من العمر سبع سنوات تقول إنها
تحمل والدتها أيضًا وتخفيها، إنهما
يعيشان الآن تحت
الدرج،
إنها حرب على حماس كما يقولون، لكنها  هو
الأصغر سناً الذي يتحمل
العبء الأكبر في فخ العنف الذي لا يستطيع
السيطرة عليه، وهو محاصر في هذا السباق ضد
الموت